right now i'm standing in the middle of  my latest property development site so  you may remember on youtube i did a  video last year and i said i've just  bought a piece of land the land cost me  330 000 pounds that's how mrs landcast i  said i was going to build six houses  from scratch and then the end value was  going to be 1.35 million i said it was  gonna cost me half a million pounds to  build the houses and people were saying  i can't imagine that i can't imagine  there'd been six houses and at the time  i was saying there's gonna be three here  there's gonna be three here and guess  what it's done so we've got three houses  right here  we've got three houses right here on  this little piece of land the values  come in by a chartered valuer at 1.35  million